my name is Nick Carter I uh I've been a
respiratory therapist since
2010 and uh I I guess the reason I'm
sending a video in is because I would
like
[Music]
to I I've never have talked about Co and
how that was how it really was um as a
respiratory therapist I worked through
that and worked in I think five
different states uh see last year I took
a job as a director for a department
made it about 8 months before I had to
uh had to step away I can't I can't do
my job anymore because of Co it if I'm
honest it completely ruined
me
um so yeah I would uh I'd like to it' be
cool to to talk
about what that was really like and what
what we as medical professionals went
through I I know that people don't get
it they don't understand how horrible
that
was Nick you're a respiratory therapist
based in uh Oklahoma Oklahoma yep Norman
Oklahoma tell me about your uh how you
got into that you went to school for it
I did yes um Kind of
a Funny Story I guess I um was working
job totally not related to the medical
field at the time and uh my best friend
and I I had met him there uh got laid
off and so he had always been talking
about different careers in the medical
field just for longevity you know and um
respiratory therapy was one of the few
that it sounded interesting and sounded
like I might actually want to try it so
uh I just decided to kind of do it um
and it just so happened that there was a
a program taking a brand new program
we're the first class to go through they
were taking some uh new students new
class and it was starting soon so just a
timing thing it just kind of worked out
and uh yeah we went to school with him
it was good you've been doing this for
how long uh 2010 is when I graduated so
started in 2009 and 2010 is yeah and at
some point in the middle of that year uh
you came across Co yeah sure did co co
changed your whole life didn't it it did
it did um in good ways and bad yeah cuz
you're you're the one who is responsible
for the ventilators which are being used
on almost every patient that was
seriously affected yeah yeah anybody
that um you know was deemed significant
enough to not be able to breathe on
their own would have to uh have to be
put on a vent we tried to delay that as
much as possible um there's another
circumstance we can get into that too um
where were you tried other things things
especially at the beginning we tried a
lot of different things yeah but um yeah
um if you are in the ICU um with any
sort of cardiopulmonary issues I was you
might have come across me uh especially
during Co you did this in several
hospitals right I did yes I I worked
in one two six Six States total during
Co yeah this because you had like
contracts that mhm yes so I would take
uh the uh let's see I just started with
emails actually that's that's how how I
got going was I got emails about
contracts that were opening up in um in
Massachusetts and um at the beginning of
covid especially for a while in in
Oklahoma where I'm from where I lived we
had zero cases and so um at that point I
had been an RT
for little over 10 years and so I kind
of felt like with the skill set my ICU
background if I if I can then I should
help um I kind of felt like I I needed
to I once I realized how bad it was is
getting I I was it was something I had
to do had to go do it so uh yeah so
Massachusetts and so that a contract
will be typically 8 to 13 weeks and then
with the option A lot of times to renew
if the hospital wants to and um
yeah so a lot of times I would renew for
maybe few more weeks and sometimes
another eight weeks or so at at certain
places um and then yeah move on I was I
was trying to move on basically to where
it was needed the most where I was I
felt like I was needed and could make
the most impact throughout Co what are
some of the States you worked in I
worked in
Massachusetts I worked in New
Jersey
Texas Wisconsin
back to New Jersey for a few different
hospitals there that time and then uh
wound up back in Oklahoma two different
hospitals in Oklahoma tell me about your
experiences with Co I'm sure you saw
things on the front line that a lot of
us didn't yep uh yeah definitely things
I won't ever
forget um what specifically would you
like to know well I mean
just you're you saw people dying I'm
sure sure I did um yeah okay we can talk
about that
so um in Dallas those were um I won't
name the hospital
but those were the the sickest sickest
patients that I've ever seen
um it it was it was wild um so I I work
T nights primarily U almost
exclusively and uh those are 12-hour
shifts uh at least um
usually usually on a contract you will
have um at least for Respiratory
contracts I know will you'll your option
will be for three four five you know
however many shifts a week um so mine
almost every single one I I did was at
least four shifts a week and then I
would pick up if I if I could
um so in Dallas
uh every every night that I worked and I
was there for I think I was there for at
least two months I think it was an 8we
contract
um the area I was in was a surgical
Suite the whole floor was a surgical
Suite that had been converted to to a CO
unit as close as we could get to one and
and we I don't mean to take anything
away from the hospitals we did as as
best as we could it was just you know
sometimes just we wish we could have
done better sometimes um so in in just
my unit
that floor at least at least one
person coated and died um every shift
that I had at least one and
um that was just that was just my unit
um the rest of the
hospital the rest of the night um you'd
still hear codes going off throughout
the rest of the hospital it was every
single night um
oh also one of the one of the I don't
know if it was sadder situations but a
situation that struck me kind of harder
than than most
um
was there was a doctor during one of
these codes at that
hospital who
um you know when you when you code a
patient there's typically you know you
just start going down the list of things
that we'll try this if it doesn't work
you go on the that
uh and yeah we had we had gone through
that list a couple of times just trying
something trying anything
um and I just man I
[Music]
just I I I don't think I've ever heard
and seen somebody look so helpless
just and this was a doctor you
know and she I I just
remember we we get to the end of this
code and she's in tears and and looking
around the room and
uh just never will forget
the uh the look that she just was
pleading with anybody in the room um and
just just the look on her face she just
begging
and she and she did she she said does
anybody have anything they can think of
that we haven't
tried does anybody have any
ideas and
uh of course it was no you know we we
all we all were out of ideas by that
point but um I just remember man that
one just feeling so helpless that
was I've never felt that helpless I
don't I don't think I ever possibly
could
again just just trying you know seeing
something in front of you that should be
impossible you know I'm there were some
patients that weren't even that critical
but I'm sitting there talking to them
like you and I are talking and you know
they their oxygen saturation is barely
in the 80s and
that's and they're having no issue no
struggle I just I that that sound that
probably doesn't sound that wild
to uh somebody on the outside but then
that's when you when you do something
especially for the decade and
then see something that has been
impossible your entire career happen
right in front of you it's just I I just
I don't I don't have a word for that
just how helpless that makes you feel
everything that you've been taught and
should be working it's just it's just
not working and you're losing patients
of all ages are these mostly older yeah
so um um I I only work with adults um
you can specialize kind of like in
nursing um so you can do pediatrics
nicku hpe stuff that that that excuse me
that type of thing um I I typically only
work with patients that are um 18 and up
um I have worked with younger patients
but during
Co I the the youngest patients that I
treated were they were around my age so
fairly young
but yeah yeah I definitely definitely
treated people that were that were my
age and that was that that hit home too
that that hit a little harder yeah did
you ever catch it I didn't uh thankfully
knock on wood I I don't know how um I
even at one point I had a tra patient
cough right in my face um of course I
had a mask and a face shield but I it
still I mean it got in my eye is as
gross as that is um but uh yeah that was
one of many many uh instances where I
know I was exposed it was just and I I
don't know how I was tested absolutely
after that time but
uh yeah somehow somehow I got lucky and
didn't didn't catch it and the hospital
was jam-packed with the
patience um at the time you mean oh yeah
yeah yeah it's every bed oh yeah yeah we
didn't have any empty beds and we had
patients doubled up in rooms um yeah I
don't an empty bed wasn't that wasn't a
thing most of the most of the places I
was at I will say um when I worked my
first I got I got kind of a ground ball
going getting into co uh when I first
started first started traveling I uh my
first contract was at a field Hospital
in Massachusetts it's which that was
cool I had never gotten to do that
before but um so we took we took
patients basically overflow from the
hospital if uh if patients
were um not critical enough where they
needed to be in the actual hospital we
would kind of free up some room and
bring them over to the field hospital um
one amazing thing and one positive thing
that I'll say about Co is this is a good
reference for that
um
we
mean everybody that showed up there
except for a few people that were sent
over from the hospital that put it on um
and this was like in a
um an event center type of thing is
where they set it up inside so it was
covered and everything but um aside from
sa from a for a few people that were
from the main hospital everybody else
was from different states and different
parts of the country and uh it was it
was amazing because you know we kind of
had the infrastructure there but then we
had to make it work once once everybody
started showing up and we we had that
thing running so smoothly so that was to
uh to be I was really proud of to be a
part
of uh you know just a group of people
that were able to come together
especially under the circumstances and
was morale like there it was good it was
really good I have to say morale was one
thing that I think we we did a pretty
good job with um even if we weren't
encouraging each other constantly uh it
was I still feel like everybody kept
each other going and kept the atmosphere
at least um difficult when you're losing
patience daily yeah I mean some days and
I you know everybody had good days and
bad days I um you
know there were plenty of days that I uh
went back to my hotel
and just uh walked in and I have a dog I
have a husky she um I would just grab
her
and cry into her I got her during Co she
traveled she's been to like 11 different
states with me she's been all over the
place but she was a she got me through
it for sure she was a huge part of me
getting through it what was the hardest
part for
you the hardest part of of
Co I don't know if I can
I don't know if I could give you just
one answer for that I mean it
was I don't know that's a that's a hard
answer that's a hard one to answer give
just one answer I mean it was for me
personally I know that um being away
from my family was very hard
um most of the time I was I was alone um
in hotels and stuff and
uh that was that was tough
um that just that the isolation
um you know and at the time even
if so us as
uh medical workers especially in the ICU
and the ER we're notor ious for being
um I don't want to call it the
atmosphere or the the the culture is not
not so much Macho but very tough
everybody wants to be tough all the time
and perceived that way and um it is
necessary I think to be to be that way
to an
extent but it takes it takes a toll and
I thought I thought for a long time that
compartmentalization was something that
I
I was I was good at and I am but just
because you put it over there and you're
able to contain it there doesn't
necessarily it's not necessarily healthy
still and we're also as healthcare
workers bad about talking about stuff um
especially
things there's not never been anything
with this magnitude I guess but
traumatic situations we're we're really
bad about talking about that and I know
personally I definitely am
um so that was it was hard to not really
you know we were so isolated everybody
was so isolated at the time even if I
wanted to talk to somebody it was it
seemed like there was kind of a limit on
how much I even
could uh but just I think the hardest
thing just had to have
been just feeling like I couldn't do
enough
I no matter what I did it just wasn't n
enough and I wanted I wanted to do more
I still I still don't think I still
don't feel like I've done enough that I
did enough and that is that's probably
the hardest the hardest thing
was seeing so many people die
and co-workers too I mean
there's there were people who I got to
know I'll be briefly but got to know
them
and then they didn't come back and you'd
hear later on that yeah they
had passed away
and man I I I have never I had never
been through anything like
that and the only the only thing that I
can
even think to compare it to not that
it's even on the same level
is is is to people that have seen war
and seen
at least death on a scale kind of like
that but again not and I don't want to
diminish anything from our our service
members at all it's tot it's different
but that's the that's just only thing I
can think to compare it to is is that
and I I just nowadays to
say PTSD it just it it feels like a
buzzword and it feels like
oh I just want attention type of thing
it's what it comes off as and it
if you worked in the hospital especially
the ICU and the ER during Co that got
PTSD to some extent for sure have
to how do you feel healthc care
hospitals the government handled this uh
emergency
um I I think we I think we definitely
should have been better prepared um I
think that
at the very minimum we should have been
better prepared um it kind of to me I
feel like Co in a way like our Health
Care system if you look at as a sort of
a shield right the semi-transparent
shield protects us from viruses and
whatnot pandemics
um I feel like Co just exposed all the
holes and all the places we were lacking
all the all the weaknesses that we had
and at least personally as as a
respiratory therapist as as somebody
who's done this for over well over a
decade I didn't know how unprepared we
were um and I felt stupid felt really
stupid that was part of I was really
angry for a while at the beginning of Co
about that I was angry
that we we just how could this have
happened how how are how is it this bad
and you know I
think that might sound silly that might
sound naive on my part and I it but
that's you know I I go to
work and I know how to do my job and and
do it pretty
well and I that's what I focus on that's
my specialty that's what I've gone to
school for that's what I
do and people this kind of ties in with
the com Ms that I've seen about anybody
in the medical field but you know you
knew what you were you should have known
what you were signing up for that type
of thing and that's yes and no I mean
when
I to me what I signed up for absolutely
was was was the chance to help people
and save lives that's I that's what I
love doing that's what I want to
continue continue to
do but I
also I also signed up to
to have the tools to do my job I also
signed up to have the
resources there to do my job
and they those things just weren't
available sometimes a lot of time a lot
of the time during Co um you know Supply
chains you name it but it just yeah
that's um and I'm not going to sit here
and say that you know as far as us being
better prepared that's not my job I'm
not saying that at all um I think now I
I feel like I have a duty to to pass on
what I've learned and to to help educate
people as best I can um was there a
burnout absolutely yeah yeah all of us I
mean there was everybody I mean to this
day I'm still I'm still dealing with
that
um just after and and I went through I
had gone through burnout before Co a
couple of times and it was
you know one of those times was in my
early mid 20s and I decided to try you
know I'd been in RT for a little while
decided to go do some other things came
back to the
field and that was really more of the
long along the lines of I think I was
looking at um looking at as looking at
it as a job and not a career I think is
is what had a lot to do with that and
once I started viewing it that way it
was better but um during
Co
I mean it probably three or four times
and the last time was the
uh kind of the final time for me I
uh I just it's hard to
explain but I just I can't do it I just
can't do it
anymore after seeing
death that much death that often for
that long I mean
just day and day out for most of it
I I just I I I can't I can't do it
anymore I and I feel that you know
doesn't help because I already feel like
I didn't do enough during Co and now you
know I certainly don't feel like I'm I'm
doing enough but
my I'd like to turn that into U teaching
people I I part of the reason I you know
had sent you the message about doing
this um um Probably sounds crazy to do
it on camera
but we we as healthcare workers we've
got to be better about talking to to
each other we got to be better about
just getting our feelings not our
feelings but just getting it off our
chest when we need to and
compartmentalization is great we have to
have that but there's got to be an
outlet at some point and I don't want to
see what I'm going through and what's
happened to me as far as the burnout and
stuff happened to to somebody else when
it doesn't because I I do feel like it's
avoidable for sure I wish that I had
started to um kind of take care of
things sooner but
um I yeah to me to me that's that's a
good way is
to know just put yourself out there and
hopefully other people will start doing
it too and start maybe not all on camera
but if it helps somebody avoid what
what's what I've kind of gone through
then that that that that would
absolutely be worth it to me for
sure what are your thoughts on the
vaccine you were required to get vaccine
yeah I did it was either get one or
don't have a job and um this was kind of
in in the middle of Co so um I did I did
have I did get it um now I never had
covid before that um so I I don't
necessarily think I should have had to
have gotten it I mean I
personally am of the
opinion that if you can demonstrate
immunity then I think you should or
resilience you know if that meant if I
had to get tested every week I was okay
with doing that but I had I had to get
the vaccine
um yeah I mean
it's you know I think I think if you are
at risk you know if you have any of the
risk factors that that they've put out
that you probably should think about
getting it um I think you know if you've
had Co a couple of times you probably
should think about getting it um but I
think kind of in like in my case and
people I know there's a lot of people
that have have not gotten it somehow and
been just fine you know I don't
necessarily agree with being forced to
get it that being said I do understand
the hospital side of it you have to have
healthy people working for you who
aren't going to pass on you know things
to your risk like oh this person was
working for the hospital and wasn't
inated and then there's a yeah ABS huge
problem there yeah so that's yeah that's
that's that's how I feel about it you
know do I agree with having to get it
personally not necessarily but um you
know it is what it is it's I got it I'm
doing fine and down the road in the
future there could be another form of
this and absolutely we could go through
this again right that's that's very
possible how did Co ultimately Fade
Away uh uh it's it's mutated and gotten
weaker I mean I the vaccine I I do
believe has helped um but I ultimately
that's it's nature doing its thing it's
it's the virus mutating and getting
weaker and um you know ever since then
things have kind of slowly been getting
better over time but there could be a
strain that takes off again there could
be there could be you never know I mean
we're we're always right around the
corner from from a a pandemic an
outbreak of some sort that's something
we don't have a whole lot of control
over and
um that what we do have control over is
you know how we respond to that and
being proactive is is is kind of what
I'm on about now and
we education is the best way to do that
you know we've got this disconnect
between the the Health Care system and
the public and that's on us that's on
that's on us as Healthcare Providers to
do better with that um I also think
that's a a lot of why there was so much
just craziness and confusion during Co
is we should have done better with being
more transparent about how we do things
explaining things when we do them with
procedure with the patient you know
simple things um and there's you know
we've got to have people that are
willing to step up and uh and educate
and and bring bring forward the Next
Generation who is going to do better who
has to do better you know there's even
Niche things like um there's a company
called avls um there's a guy named Joe
Lewis um he actually is a respiratory
therapist he's got a a channel and stuff
um they do they do education with with
EMT Crews with flight Crews and you know
that's that seems kind of like maybe to
somebody like well why would respiratory
therapists do vent education with those
guys well that's if they go out on a
crazy call and pick you up you know it's
on a helicopter doctor or an ambulance
ride that vent is keeping you alive back
to the hospital so that's something
that's one area that I hadn't even
considered um that's pretty cool is you
know Niche stuff is great and I know
there's lots of people who probably
think that they may not have the
greatest idea on what to educate and
stuff on but there's there's a room for
all of it especially with YouTube
YouTube is the future for a lot of
things but I think our industry for
sure all right Nick thank you so much
for giving us your thoughts on what you
went through with covid absolutely as a
respiratory therapist and uh I wish you
all the luck in the world in the future
thank you so much thanks for having me
thank
you